how often do you watch a movie or TV
show that you hate
I try to avoid watching movies or TV
shows that I hate
right now I think the one that I'm
watching that I vehemently dislike
is the Lord of the Rings the rings of
power
I I mean it's um but even but even then
I don't really hate the show I'm
I just don't care
but I feel
I I feel it's important that in order to
have an opinion about something
need to have seen it there's there there
is quite a contingent of people who have
lots of thoughts and opinions about
things that they know nothing about
and I believe it was Harlan Ellison who
taught me that
um the common phrase that you've heard
everyone has the right to their opinion
is incorrect
you only have a right to your informed
opinion
so generally
I like to wait to see
a TV show or a movie
before I form an opinion about it
there have been plenty of cases where
trailers especially these days the
trailers and marketing are deceptive
they represent completely differently
what a show is going to be I think a lot
of that is pandering to to journalists
to try to get them to think a certain
way about something but
I I don't know I think when it comes to
hate watching anything for me that
normally comes
comes along the lines of like reality
television
which reality television is like
is like it's like potato chips not good
for you they're not good for you
but I'm like that was the worst thing
ever I can't stand it this character I
can't believe that she's with him and
he's with her why did they break up and
get back together and I'm going to open
up another bag of chips so I tend to not
hate watch movies but I will 100 percent
hate watch reality television which is
its own form of Storytelling
and just to kind of give a little
background of where that came from
um the the sort of competitive reality
TV shows like Survivor and whatnot
can be traced back to a documentary
called hands on a hard body
which is a movie that I believe played
Sundance and it's about a Texas truck
dealership car dealership that every
year they'd have a little promotion on
the radio where they would give away a
truck for free
all you had to do and they would select
people from the radio listening audience
and they would be selected as
contestants where they all they had to
do was put their hands on a truck and
the last person who still has their
hands on the truck gets to keep the
truck
this is a documentary film that I
strongly recommend that you seek out but
it's a documentary subject that you know
it's got a setup it's got a bunch of
variety of characters that we meet it's
got your main conflict you've got like
what the the goal of each character is
you know I want to get the truck because
my my old truck is not working I got you
know you meet all these different types
of people walks of life they do get
bathroom breaks right but you got to
keep your hands on that truck
and that
the success of that documentary I
believe led to these competitive reality
shows
I mean it's all storytelling right I
mean there are you'll see in the credits
small story producer right on a reality
show because they create these conflicts
but if I hate watch anything it's bad
reality television
and I hope you'll forgive me
you're forgiven I've done the same
but what is it what what do you get from
it like when you know it's like you know
you're supposed to stop doing something
but you can't what payoff do you get I
guess the payoff from you know hate
watching Bad reality TV for me is uh I
wanna I wanna see
I want to see a good outcome for the
people that I care about right so I want
to see the winner get the prize okay I
want to see the couple that should be
together remain together the couple that
should part let them go their separate
ways so I'd like to see some sort of
positive outcome it never really goes
that way but I do find reality
television
reality television is is useful it's
useful in terms of being able to
identify that this is storytelling like
other storytelling forms so you can't
completely dismiss it but I only ever
hate watch those shows
how much do you think hate watching has
increased in the last few years
well for me not that much I I feel like
my time is is is really valuable in
terms of like trying to juggle a lot of
projects you know I do a movie website I
have my own YouTube channel and I make
make movies on the side and um I don't
have a lot of time so if I'm going to
invest in something you know I'm hoping
for a good experience so I don't hate
watch stuff as much as I used to but if
I'm gonna hate watch anything it's
usually something where I want to
completely turn my brain off
which is always going to be something
from reality TV but it's interesting
that the roots of reality TV can be
traced to a little documentary from
decades ago and I think what was the
Seven Up series or something by the
British director
try to think of what yeah seven up that
was where this British director
Revisited kids every seven years just to
see how they evolved and developed not
particularly a competition show per se
but an interesting kind of check-in uh
you know with like well how are they
surviving right
um yeah don't feel bad I got suckered
into Joe Millionaire I did also oh my
God you're one of the few people who've
seen that show
I you know I had tried to get my cable
shut off uh because I wanted to go cold
turkey I didn't want any more
distractions and then Joe Millionaire
came along and I but I didn't hate watch
it I was just intrigued by it
but but I can see that there is a trend
and we see it online and it's become a
new sport to hate watch
um and so I just was curious why
we we've tipped the scales well yeah not
everything has to be you know when we
eat not everything has to be a salad or
stuff that's good for us you know you
can have a a cheeseburger from a fast
food restaurant and not everything in
our media consumption has to be a social
justice documentary that's very you're
being told is very important and you
feel really good for having sat there
and watched it I'm informed I'm
enlightened now
so um yeah you can you can watch bad
reality TV I won't judge okay thanks
well the road rules weren't wasn't bad
that was when you first would kind of
like set it off as well but Road Rules
and the real world
MTV that was an interesting one so yeah
no all of that stuff
how do you deal with hate watching
because you have to watch so many things
but I don't like like I don't really
hate watching this since like I don't
know what I'm gonna see like I see a lot
of Indie movies that nobody sees see a
lot of independent films
um I may end up hating the movie at the
end but I'm always hopeful I'm always
optimistic
I'm always optimistic and especially
when it comes to Independent films you
know
um I tend to overlook flaws
because to me an independent film is
like a bird with a broken wing I want to
see it flourish I want to see it fly I
want to see it you know uh go on and
have its best possible life
but Independent films the deck is always
stacked against independent filmmakers
budget wise resources marketing
resources
it's it's the fact that you can make
anything watchable on an indie level is
remarkable to me so I always look for
that
so you're not setting out sorry to hate
it no no now I'm not setting out to hate
in in especially an independent film but
there are independent films I've seen
that I really hated by the end oh man
I'm not gonna name names but they exist
quite a few